und bei uns begrüße ich jetzt ganz
herzlich die ex präsidentin von bela
russin svetlana an oskar schön dass sie
bei uns sind guten tag
ist das team
der angriff auf katar wäre jetzt vor
allem von belarus aus was macht das mit
ihnen als faktisch gewählte exil
präsidenten ihres landes
in der ukraine begann
woher wurde das zu einer neuen realität
für
weißrussland denn wir haben sehr lange
für neue walen gekämpft bei uns im land
für die befreiung der politischen
gefangenen und jetzt müssen die
weissrussen nicht nur gegen das
lukaschenko regime kämpfen sondern auch
gegen den krieg in der ukraine und die
meisten
weißrussen haben natürlich die seite der
ukraine gewählt und sie machen
manifestationen demonstrationen gehen
auf die straße und die
weißrussen die gezwungen waren
belarus zu verlassen wegen der
repressalien helfen jetzt der ukraine
ganz massiv und wir haben also alle
alles was wir zur verfügung haben jetzt
für die ukraine fürchten sie gestehen
dass diktator lukaschenko jetzt
eventuell auch belarussische soldaten in
die ukraine schicken könnte
da passen ist persönliche fahrer bestand
und besteht immer noch wir wissen dass
letzten montag die
weißrussischen die weißrussische armee
die weißrussische ukrainische grenze
überqueren sollte aber irgendwas ist
schief gegangen und ich denke dass die
situation dass die weißrussen massenhaft
signale ausgesandt haben an unsere
soldaten sich also nicht gegen das
bruder erfolg gegen das bruder volk zu
richten und sie haben sich an die mutter
gewandt und gesagt schickt eure söhne
nicht in den sicheren tod sie sehen ja
was in der ukraine passiert und deshalb
sind die weissrussen ganz offensichtlich
nicht über die grenze die wagen in die
ukraine dennoch könnte lukaschenko sie
quasi dazu zwingen glauben sie dass sie
dann einfach verweigern würden
möglicherweise haben die weißrussischen
soldaten auf zur vernunft zu kommen und
die befehle von lukaschenko nicht
auszuführenden sie haben den treueeid
gegenüber ihrem volk geschworen und ich
gegenüber dem präsidenten und natürlich
kann es passieren dass dieser befehl
gegeben wird aber es wird natürlich von
den soldaten abhängen ob sie diesen
befehl ausführen oder nicht was glauben
sie erwartet die ukraine sollte putin
diesen krieg gewinnen
ehrlich gesagt möchte ich mir das gar
nicht vorstellen
dass die ukraine womöglich verliert denn
ich sehe die ukraine ich sehe ihren mut
ihre opferbereitschaft sie
verteidigen ihre heimat aber wenn es
doch so passieren sollte wenn die
gesamte demokratische welt nicht in der
lage sein sollte der ukraine zu helfen
in diesen dramatischen moment so ist die
unabhängigkeit der ukraine und die
unabhängigkeit von baross matur lich
gefährdet und wir sind schon sozusagen
aus dem einflussbereich entkommen von
russland wir haben eine eigene nation
gebildet die ukraine genauso wie belarus
und wir wollen selbst entscheiden wie
unsere länder sich entwickeln und wohin
wir gehen würden aber das wird natürlich
wenn das tatsächlich passieren sollte
kein kein kein verlust oder kein nicht
das verlieren der ukraine sein sondern
das verlieren der demokratie nun finden
tatsächlich in belarus ja immer wieder
jetzt der friedensverhandlungen
vermittlungsrunden statt wieviel chance
geben sie diesen vermittlungsrunden
bis jetzt wissen sie
man muss jede möglichkeit ergreifen
um
diese gespräche zum erfolg zu führen
denn menschliche menschliches leben
steht auf dem spiel steht die
infrastruktur wenn wir die bombardierten
häuser und die bombardierten betriebe
sehen so ist das natürlich schrecklich
aber wir müssen verstehen und nachweisen
dass die ukraine stark ist und die
ukraine kann nur dann stark sein wenn
sie von den demokratischen staaten
unterstützt wird ich hoffe sehr dass die
dritte etappe der verhandlungen heute
irgend etwas bringen wird wenigstens die
eröffnung von humanitären korridoren für
die friedliche bevölkerung der ukraine
und die ukraine muss natürlich ihre
stärke fühlen dank der unterstützung der
gesamten welt und sie muss stark sein
stärke beweisen in den verhandlungen sie
kann keine zugeständnisse machen die sie
sich eigentlich nicht erlauben dürfte
sagt die ex präsidentin von belarus
svetlana ceca oscar vielen dank dass sie
bei uns waren dankeschön
vielen dank